what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Oh Lord we got half Church in here a
marvel legacy man man I'm excited
Marvin legacy number one is so good oh
my god dude this story is so good this
is literally Marvel's DC Reapers that's
what this is now whether or not the rest
of this will hold up to the one shot I
don't know I mean those stories have a
come out yet but for right now man
dude this is god this is absolutely
amazing okay so yours the deal more of a
legacy is Marvel's response to all-new
all-different marvel Marvel's going back
to the drawing board and they're saying
okay fine let's just do this
DC rebirth ask sort of thing Marvel
legacies designed for that purpose it's
designed to basically take Marvel
quote-unquote back to its roots dare I
say it's probably entirely possible to
read like Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers and then read Secret
Wars and then read this like literally
skip over all-new all-different marvel
now we will see things references to
like secret Empire
stuff like that but we don't know if
that's never going to play a role later
on but what this additionally does is it
actually picks up about a billion years
ago and it picks out I'm sorry a million
years ago rather and it picks up with I
guess the earliest iteration of the
Avengers what Marvel is basically saying
at the moment is that the Avengers as a
team which is to say people who fight to
save the world have always been around
there's always been a team that served
the purpose of saving the world in this
instance is actually Odin alongside the
Phoenix and a handful of others now
we'll get to you who these characters
are here in a second but it's actually
an intriguing concept and the reason why
is because what this does is this takes
the origin of the Marvel Universe in a
lot of ways and it incorporates itself
into it and then it makes a few
modifications for example we have seen
instances where Marvel has given us like
the origin of the Celestials and they
say in the origin of the Celestials
they're responsible for the creation of
all things but we've also seen stories
where it's basically Odin who's
responsible for the creation of all
things and that seems to be the case
here it seems to be that what's going on
here is Marvel's drawing on the old
tales of Asgard stories well they
basically had this origin of Asgard
itself and saying that it was basically
the creation of the world tree Idris so
the actions of Odin that led to the
formation of earth the weird scenario
here is the Phoenix now for those
who don't know the Phoenix force is a
character that actually has an origin
and it was covered in the Excalibur
comics but there wasn't a whole lot to
it in truth a lot of people don't know
about the origin of the Phoenix a lot of
folks never read Excalibur a lot of
folks don't really know how that works
but the weight of Phoenix functions is
it's basically the sum total of all life
and psionic energy that has ever
currently does and will ever exist
across the multiverse there's only ever
one Phoenix force in the whole
multiverse but it does have different
house in each individual universe what
this story does and what Jason Aaron as
a writer is actually doing is he's
coming back and saying the Phoenix and
Odin have a long-standing history
together and there's room for this
because the Phoenix force's history
before in encounter Jean Grey is
basically a blank slate you can
literally write whatever you want to and
it fits in what this also does is it
hits back to the nature of the hammer as
it was created by Odin now for those of
you guys who are not familiar with the
history of Odin Suns hammer for years
and years and years and Marvel Comics it
was really just this idea that like the
hammer was created by the dwarves and it
was taken by Odin and it had some
magical enchantments put on it and then
Odin Sun lifted it one day and he'd been
lifting it ever since up until he lost
his ability to lift it and that was
really it what Jason Aaron did is he
came back and he said well actually
there was this cosmic storm called the
god Tempest and it was literally a storm
that was capable of going through and
annihilating entire systems and so what
Odin did is he actually thought the
storm can find it inside of a piece of
metal and had that uber metal turned
into the hammer at this point the god
tempest is still inside the hammer and
the reason we know this is because Odin
is struggling to lift the hammer because
it has its own sentience because it has
its own power and that's kind of the
cool thing about it going forward
Odin realized the hammer was just too
dangerous for any one person to lift and
so he simply just you know sat it down
and put enchantment that only those who
were worthy could lift the hammer and
that was it it just sat there forever
and ever and ever until Odin's son was
able to pick it up but what this also
does is it gives us characters like star
brand and gives us characters like a
like an iron fist that existed a million
years ago a Black Panther that existed a
million years ago and that's the cool
thing because again if you're familiar
with the history of the Marvel Universe
all this stuff makes sense it fits in
perfectly the star brand for example is
an interesting concept the star brand is
basically this idea
there's something called the white event
and the wide event is basically a
scenario where a universe will face a
threat of such an extreme degree or the
sentient society on earth or any
sentient society within any of the
worlds in a universe will reach a point
where they're ready to handle a power of
such extreme measure and what will
happen is a wide Opena trigger and when
that white event triggers then a person
is selected to be a star brand now it's
kind of weird because originally the
star brand basically had as much power
as they needed to defeat any foe in any
particular point in time the problem
with this is that during the events of
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers they
were fighting foes capable of destroying
cosmic entities if the star brand may
maintained its original role then there
would have been no need for anybody else
the star brand would just killed
everybody and so the result is a star
brands power was actually decreased in
order to make him just a run-of-the-mill
super hero with all different kinds of
you know energy abilities and so on and
so forth but what this tells us is that
going all the way back to the earliest
days of Earth's history that these other
dimensions still existed Asgard
dimensions like you know we're vast
resides dimensions like Kunlun different
things like that those have always been
there it's just only recently that we
ever found out that they were actually
there one of the new exceptions here is
a celestial called the fallen now we
don't know anything about this guy I've
never heard of this celestial before but
Celestials are inherently beings of
insane power and these Avengers actually
manage to defeat it now keep in mind
this celestial seems to be weaker than
the others and the reason why is because
even Odin himself would struggle against
the full might of a celestial in this
scenario they faced off against it and
they do end up defeating it but we don't
really see how that happens instead we
just kind of see them rushing into
battle and then that's really about it
what we end up doing here is we pick up
with Rabi Reyes now this is a part of
the story that seems to come out of
nowhere but in fact it actually works
and the reason why is because it'll
actually pick up with the end of this
story in terms of what the aftermath of
this is but again Marvel legacy is
designed to give people a tour of the
Marvel Universe of sorts but also begins
setting up these individual character
arcs that will go forward with in Marvel
Comics now Robby Raees is basically this
guy who's possessed by the spirit of Eli
Morrow and what this does is it allows
him to basically become a Ghost Rider
but in the scenario what he ends up
doing is actually running the
into the new star brand are running
directly into a Kevin Connor I think his
name is now it's kind of weird because
this is the version of star brand that
we saw in Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers the kicker is that when
like a secret Empire happened he was
just one of the heroes who was cast out
of earth he originally was in a story
alongside a night mask which was
cancelled after like 12 issues it didn't
last very long which was really
disappointing because we got a huge
exploration of the Marvel cosmology and
the different cosmic entities but nobody
really seemed to be interested in it at
the time and so because of that it was
really far bran just kind of faded into
the background and that was really about
it
in this scenario he actually ends up
attacking Rabi Reyes now the reason for
this seems to be that he's basically
just hiding out the issue is that when
he gets into a fight with Robbie Reyes
it draws out the Ghost Rider and so
again this is a really cool scenario but
before we end up finding out what
happens with that what we do is we jump
to Loki now remember Loki has his own
scheme his own thing going on with
regards to like Asgard and the Thor
stories that are being written right now
and so on and so forth he basically has
a larger role to play but we don't
really know what that role is presumably
this fits into it and the reason why is
because where he's been working behind
the scenes and where there seems to
basically be some sort of ulterior
motive going on between loki and Frigga
we don't really know again what the
secret role is if he's a double agent or
whatever the case may be but it's this
long-running scheme that he's been
having really since all-new
all-different marvel started and so this
part basically seems to come into play
when he grabs these you know frost
giants so they're basically kind of cast
off and then takes them into area 51 for
the purpose of going through and trying
to find some sort of artifact now the
arrival of these frost giants trying to
find whatever this artifact is it brings
the attention of Jane Foster Thor of Sam
Wilson again back in this modern day
right now and they basically just start
fighting the frost giants I mean this
it's pretty straightforward what ends up
happening is that one of them actually
grabs the box they're supposed to be
getting and then simply just takes off
now there are a couple things that
happen in between this most notably with
Steve Rogers and with Odin's son and the
reason why is because in the aftermath
of secret Empire as we've covered again
you'll find that playlist down in the
description Steve Rogers you know with
his official return and defeating the
Hydra version of himself he's basically
just kind of gone and hiding he's
basically playing at Loki he's kind of
taking a break from everything remember
right now Sam Wilson still Captain
America and so for the moment Steve
Rogers has not stepped into that role
now he probably will because he does
have a Captain America shield this sets
the stage for the idea that going
forward he will resume his role and most
likely you'll have Sam Wilson annual
have Steve Rogers operating as Captain
America at same time no clue but the
biggest part of this is it switches over
to Odin Sun and what this ends up doing
is it gives us a one-page statement that
there is a being and Asgardian on the
Bifrost bridge that basically connects
these different worlds and allows us
guardians to jump from one world to the
next
this guy had a glimpse that a being
called man GOG is making a return now
Magog is crazy dude this guy is a
villain is and isn't hence Magog is
basically indestructible
he literally feeds his own power by
feeding on the fear of everybody around
the universe it's super super cool if I
remember correctly he has like you know
enough strength to kill virtually any
Asgardian of super speed all different
kinds of things but he can also
manipulate matter now how extensive that
will be I don't know I mean it was mad
at manipulation confined to like the
Walt Simonson era of Thor at the time
and so we don't really know like how
extensive it'll be now versus how it was
then but he was certainly a wrecking
ball like it was enough to decimate
virtually anybody but one of the other
huge reveals here is we end up finding
out that Tony Stark is missing Tony
Stark's body's gone and no one knows
where it went it's just out there
somewhere
nobody has any clue about what's going
on with it now of course switching back
over to this fight between star brand
and Robby Reyes it's a pretty important
battle between the two in the middle of
all this star brand is hit with a
pendant stare of you know Robby Reyes of
Howard that he never had before but the
reason why this matters is because in
this moment star brand basically sees
what's coming and what he realizes is
that a celestial the Fallen will awaken
and he will call the final host and when
he does all hell is gonna break loose
and that's exactly what takes place what
is up happening here is that in the
aftermath of this fight between Robby
Reyes and star brand bleed of having a
couple of guys who make their way down
into this cave they're destroyed by the
Fallen celestial and he simply says some
in the final host cleanse them all now
the reason why this is so important the
reason why this is necessary is because
of the fact that the celestial host is
basically an instance of judgment to get
a little bit of history here then Marvel
Comics if we take this history this new
history into account and we say okay so
Odin was really responsible for like the
creation of earth if we say that the
rest of the history still remains intact
that somewhere along the line the
celestial showed up on earth and they
modified the genes of humans so that
some humans would become mutants they
would have an X gene that would activate
somewhere along the line and other
humans would have their genes activated
so that when they were blasted with
gamma radiation instead of just being
irradiated with tumors they would turn
into the Incredible Hulk what they ended
up doing was coming back periodically to
basically check on their experiment now
the arrival of those Celestials were
called hosts and there have been a
handful of them over the years this
would basically be the fifth host but
what this means is that if the
Celestials come back there will be a
celestial that will basically look upon
everything that's going on and all the
other Celestials will defer to their
judgment I believe it's a Shema the
judge and what will happen is that this
celestial will say everything is going
according to plan where things are not
going according to plan if things are
not going in according to plan they will
sanitize the entirety of the planet and
I'll be honest with you guys there's no
one on the earth right now who would be
able to stop them not one but again
picking up with this story as we
continue on the one is up happening is
we basically have these little
interjections for stories that are
coming later on down the line in the
Alpha Flight deep-space monitoring
station out in New Mexico one of the
guys walks away from monitoring signals
only for us to find out that as soon as
this happens a signal comes in from
Sekar basically these people saying we
need the incredible hope to come back a
hit back to the events of Planet Hulk we
also end up having these these really
interesting moments I mean when we end
up finding out this member of the frost
giants had made off with this case he as
soon as he takes off he's immediately
hit by a Mack truck and when he is the
person inside is the original Wolverine
all we know is that during the events of
the death of Wolverine he was literally
encased in adamantium it was just
adamantium that was liquefied and poured
all over his skin and he died inside of
it but we don't know how he got out all
we know is that he did and he's here now
what we also end up finding out when he
kills this frost giant is the artifact
that they were going after was an
infinity stone
it was the space stone so again this is
huge because we basically have this
whole thing where like Gamora looks at
everything and says somebody is running
around and trying to gather the Infinity
stones again and so it was awesome to
see these coming back because this is
really the only way that anybody would
be able to defeat the final celestial
house at least that seems to be the case
but what ends up taking place is we jump
out of everything that's happening on
earth into the middle of nowhere
god only knows what's going on and we
end up finding out so this story as it
existed has been narrated by the larrya
Richards who's accompanied by Franklin
Richards
the children of Reed and they say dad
has another universe for us to explore
so the exploration of the multiverse as
it's being created by Reed Richards
Franklin and valaria and Susan and
molecule man is still taking place the
aftermath to secret wars is still going
on
not only that this is the first time
that we basically end up seeing any
reference of any kind to Reed Richards
in the main Marvel Universe the idea
that we actually see him being
acknowledged is still being alive this
is a massive moment now whether or not
the Fantastic Four will actually come
back together we don't know but this is
an amazing story because all Marvel
legacy is designed to do is basically
say here's where each individual
character arc is gonna start picking up
that the Incredible Hulk or even Amadeus
Cho Hulk is gonna go back to Planet Hulk
they're gonna go back to the car that
we're gonna have all these events taking
place Deadpool's a villain now you know
he's back to being a bad guy but it's
also the concept that we're probably
gonna see some exploration about what's
been going on with Reed Richards and
company what they've been doing ever
since Secret Wars ended to me that's the
most exciting part because if we end up
getting a book like that I imagine it'll
just be a tour of the multiverse it'll
just be all these different universes
and the differences between those and
the main Marvel Universe but I'm so
excited because if all the other stories
that come out after this follow the
trend as it's been established here it's
gonna be one hell of a ride but when
that being said if you guys are new here
to come this explain makes you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like make sure you
check the description there will be a
playlist with all the character story
arcs Iron Man Thor The Incredible Hulk
Captain America all of which lead
directly into Secret Wars and then
directly into this of course will also
do Hickman's
vendors and New Avengers I'm waiting for
infinity war to drop before we actually
release that video you're ready for the
trailer to drop anyway but anyway guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]